[Music]
over on CDF young Sheldon dances his way
onto TV tonight at eg outlines Leon
Aguilera was on the set of The Big Bang
Theory spin-off with this new leading
mini man in Armitage everybody excited
to start school Monday I am how is
Sheldon coping being a high schooler
when he's really supposed to be inside
Sheldon is terribly unhappy and terribly
happy it's the same guy me he's like her
the student dress and grooming code this
boys wearing sports attire outside of a
designated area and this girl's blouse
is diaphanous which means I can see her
brassiere
I felt like Neil Armstrong on the moon
alone and happy Jim Parsons does the
shows narration but how much is young
Sheldon like the older version bazinga
bazinga are we ever gonna get to hear
you say bazinga
I don't think we are I'm so hoping I'm
still hoping fingers cross fingers
crossed oh you will lose Inga I see you
just heard it ahh it's gonna be a fun
night of TV can't wait for this Big Bang
engagement and then young Sheldon
absolutely thought of eating butter
zenit right
[Music]
you